then a few years later Jenna Dewan went
on lip sync battle she did a really
great Magic Mike number
[Applause]
I
pretty much watch it every day
little me unless she didn't know she was
gay JoJo siwa revealing Jenna Dewan
played a part in her gay Awakening
should have known I was gay and Jenna's
fully aware of it chiming in to say
she's never been more honored ah it
feels amazing it all started when JoJo
took on this Tick-Tock Trend one thing
about me is that when I was 12 telling a
personal story set to the tune of Nicki
Minaj's super freaky girl one thing
about me is that when I was 12 Demi
Lovato came out with the song cool for
the summer
[Music]
I really really like the end listen to
it all the time I did not know what it
meant back then but now that I'm much
older than I understand I know what I
mean I like just putting it out there
from there JoJo's gay Awakening
continued thanks to Jenna then a few
years later Jenna Dewan went on lip sync
battle
[Music]
she did a really great Magic Mike number
I pretty much watch it every day
little me and she didn't know she was
gay
well the Step Up star saw JoJo's post
and stitched it to react she captioned
the clip Jojo I have never been more
honored I pretty much watch it every day
little me unless she didn't know she was
gay JoJo came out in January of last
year with fittingly a series of posts on
Tick Tock first lip syncing to Lady
Gaga's Born This Way
then sharing this snap on Insta rocking
a shirt reading best gay cousin ever I
mean I'm so happy I I think every little
gay human knows when they're a kid and
it's something that you hide inside
until you are ready to share with the
world and finally sharing it with the
world and having the world accept me and
celebrate me just felt so nice and now
JoJo sharing even more a couple years
later a man
was my first date yeah The Tick Tock
tale continues with the final chapter of
her coming out journey and he
wanted to have sex with me
and I
did not want to never wanted to gross
out by the thought of it immediately new
men are not my thing women on my game
gotta go you know what my mom said to me
the other day my mom said to me I love
how
comfortable you are with being gay and I
was like
what do you mean and she's like well
you're just not like afraid of it and I
think that you make me feel better about
it because I don't know how to act
around you about it but you you know you
make jokes and you are funny about it so
I think that me coming out for me has
just made me feel like
anything is okay
[Music]